cette sculpture est une véritable
miraculée des guerres après avoir
échappé à la révolution elle intègre le
musée des monuments français ou
alexandre lenoir le conservateur est
convaincu qu'il s'agit d'un bus de
jeanne d'arc
après avoir survécu à la destruction du
château de gaillon et à la révolution
elle intègre le musée des monuments
français ou alexandre lenoir son
conservateur est convaincu qu'il s'agit
d'un bus de jeanne d'arc
un peu mutilé il l'a fait compléter
comme dans le portrait des échevins
d'orléans afin d'en faire une véritable
effigie de la grande figure jouannic
après le démantèlement du musée des
monuments français elle intègre les
galleries historique de versailles avant
de rejoindre l'hôtel cabu à orléans ou
en 1940 elle fait les frais des flammes
qui dévaste la ville paradoxalement il
s'agit là d'une des ses oeuvres qui a
échappé aux flammes et a pu être
réintégré les collections du musée des
beaux-arts
[Musique]